la ministre délégué à l'industrie agnès
pannier rue nager s'est rendu à
l'entreprise daco bello à ablis sur la
circonscription de la députée aurore
bergé également présente avec le pdg
elles ont pu découvrir les étapes de
fabrication des produits dako bello
beaucoup de machines mais qui ne
fonctionne pas tout seul et créer des
emplois
elles ont découvert tous les processus
de cette entreprise familiale de taille
intermédiaire spécialisé depuis près de
50 ans dans l'importation et le
conditionnement de fruits secs sécher et
de graines du monde entier outre les
dégustations l'objet de cette visite la
reconquête industrielle sur un cas très
concret on voit tout ce que peut
apporter l'industrie ça sera pour nous
un enjeu majeur
on va pas se mentir on est dans une
crise mondiale
on entend ici et là des chiffres
inquiétants de suppressions d'emplois
mais on voit aussi que l'industrie peut
créer de l'emploi qu'il ya des belles
histoires là c'est une histoire de
reprise d'un cycle était en difficulté
reprise où tous les salariés ont été
repris et reprise finalement conduit à
continuer à recruter
vous parliez de 200 emplois
supplémentaires prochainement recruter
voilà comment on peut avec des sites
industriels main dans la main avec les
industriels permettre de reconstruire
notre économie
durand lakovic 19 très peu de chômage
partiel pour cette entreprise 15
personnes seulement et des produits
alimentaires plébiscitée pendant la
période du confinement
le message qui doit passer c'est un
message de de la réalité du nom d'une
entreprise pme ou eti implantées sur le
territoire avec plus de 200 salariés et
qui évidemment les problématiques qui
d'une entreprise pendant la crise post
crise on a pu montrer tout à l'heure
lors de la visite surligne les les
premiers prototypes de papier qui
remplace le plastique d'emballage papier
qui remplace le plastique cdd moment
très important dans l'histoire de
l'entreprise
le chiffre d'affaires de l'entreprise
est de 80 millions d'euros dako bello se
tournent à présent vers lee commerce